yeah I probably should have done a video
on that Punisher trailer probably too
late now but whatever let's talk about
this one friend request not unfriended
that's another moment it's ultimately
the premise and friend request is
there's this weird girl in this College
she's gonna awkward she wears the hood
she sits in the corner she stares at her
computer she's socially a little strange
starts talking to the main girl in the
movie the main girl gets a friend
request on facebook from her she accepts
it in this girl we're talking all the
alarms are going off I was blowing up
her feed blowing up her messages trying
to FaceTime her all the time red flag I
would do exactly what this girl does
which is just like delete then the girl
kills herself and then this evil
malevolent force is picking off all the
girls friends one by one who's funny the
more I talk about the more absurd that
premise sounds a girl gets deleted off
of another girl's Facebook friend list
and kills herself and now this spirit is
killing that girl's friends what we have
ultimately is a big jump scare fest is
what the movie is
however touching on the jump scares the
jump scares in this movie we're
remarkably more effective than a lot of
other movies that use jump scares then
again someone could come up behind me in
the movie theater just be like I know
jump at that - just startling this
horror movie is still built on the brick
and mortar of jump scares not characters
no one in this movie stands out to me
there's a relationship that builds I
didn't feel it is everybody who died I
was like who's that person again oh yeah
there's a fur in that one group thing it
that whatever let's get on to the next
two deaths this movie makes an attempt
at almost being relevant this movie
briefly at a point touches on the fact
that people are so engrossed with social
media that it's social media is
ultimately becoming more real life than
real life I find that fascinating
because it's the thing that I see in the
world - as the movie goes on people
unfriend the main girl's Facebook page
and it shows the count dropping he just
comes across as ridiculous because it's
like oh [ __ ] they didn't hit the point
home the movie at no point is some
social study on Facebook friends and
what it means and some people how
important it is to them you're losing
the faceless people you never even
talked to in your school okay it's like
this movie's a hybrid of two different
movies it's like two different people
with two different film pitches came to
the same studio exact one guy was like I
want to make a movie that's a social
study about how Facebook isn't grossing
the lives of the people someone else was
like I want to make a movie where the
ghost of a dead person is killing off
the Friends of the
person till that person might not have
any friends laughs all your friends dead
by George that's got to be about as
lonely as having no friends on face and
then he merged them together and then we
have this movie is even the cops in this
movie yes there are dead people so they
were gonna be cops they're going after
the main girl and her face books
ultimately possessed so is posting the
videos of the people getting killed and
the cops are like so let me get this
straight this video just magically
appeared on your timeline yeah it's
called a hack that's kind of what
happens right you've never heard of that
no one just hacks a facebook page why
that is impossible it's weird it's like
they're coming after this girl when she
clearly has alibis she's not involved
with the murders she's not responsible
for the deaths like when the deans like
well we're getting a lot of pressure we
might have to expel you and she's trying
to explain to them that she can't delete
her facebook page I wanted to just bust
out a laptop be like look it's not
letting me delete it do you believe me
now great I'm gonna go back and study or
watch my friends die whatever because
the cops are [ __ ] morons guys in the
end friend requests it has a couple of
moments this is one dude near the end
who actually does a logical thing
jump-scare they don't really wrap it up
it's like they got to the end of the
movie they were like how do we wrap it I
don't know in credits it's like two
different halves of two different kind
of thought-out movies that merge into
one stupid [ __ ] half assed
thought of one movie it's nothing
special I my eyes were watering I was so
bored in this marriage and then the end
battles' a friend request is not gonna
be remembered in t-minus one day yep
already forgot alright guys so friend
requests have you seen it what did you
think about it but what's the worst
horror movie out there that you've seen
lately whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]